en búsqueda de una salida este martes
mientras las fuerzas hermanas seguían
reprimiendo nuevas protestas con balas
reales de goma y con chorros de agua se
reunieron los ministros de asuntos
exteriores de los países miembros de la
asociación de naciones del sudeste
asiático asean para ejercer presión
sobre la junta militar que tomó el poder
en mianmar
sean la asean se reunió para encontrar
soluciones pero se necesitan dos para
bailar el tango la buena voluntad de la
acea no puede llevarse a cabo si mianmar
no abre la puerta a la asean que indigna
los países vecinos están preocupados por
la escalada de violencia en mianmar que
se ha cobrado un importante número de
vidas el domingo fue el día más
mortífero desde el golpe de estado con
18 muertos dejaron acceso a la ayuda
humanitaria crear un clima propicio al
diálogo muchas fueron las peticiones
durante la cumbre por otra parte varios
países entre los cuales la potencia
regional singapur exigieron la
liberación de los detenidos políticos
con sus actuales arrestar a un sand
sushi así como a sus ministros y al
presidente y acusarlos de delitos y
cosas así no creo que vaya a ayudar a
resolver el problema hay que volver a
liberar a un sándwich y negociar con
ella y su equipo y elaborar una vía
pacífica para mí anmat y uruguay power
por mi alma una preocupación global
compartida por países occidentales eeuu
advirtió este lunes a los gobernantes
militares de mianmar que tomarían más
medidas si siguen matando a personas
desarmadas la participación de la asean
tras el golpe de estado ha sido
duramente criticada por activistas
birmanos pues aseguran que sólo están
dándole legitimidad al régimen militar